six one seven eight three zero 4750 you
know I'm gonna go to re re last time he
called in had a question about Iran and
Russia and we sort of mixed it up
together and I'm wondering what's on
Artie's mind today re go ahead if that's
you I David thanks for taking my call
actually I going a different route - do
they talk about ya what your your take
is generally on the open borders
argument because from my perspective
philosophically I agree with the idea
that you know people should not be
confined to you know their area
especially if they're you know danger
and all that type of stuff and there's a
lot of libertarian art they cannot
economist actually are proponents of it
but I it seems to me that it's not we're
not at a time in history where it seems
to be feasible without there being sort
of a lot of chaos and and I was just
curious what what do I mean does he
ideally if there was a situation where
the West completely opened up its
borders then you know obviously you know
there's a rise of right-wing nationalism
in a lot of these guys okay so Ari let
me ask you this let me ask you this Ari
when yes I open borders open borders
could mean a bunch of different things
sometimes other people say open borders
they mean you still literally have a
border and and border crossings and
immigration but anyone who wants to move
to the US is allowed to move to the US
if you want to live here there's no
process but you've got to just tell us
you tell us I want to go live in the US
and you were allowed to come in that's
one version of open borders another is
literally there is no border or
immigrations and customs enforcement at
all like it's a completely uncontrolled
border which do you mean by open borders
I mean I think your your the the former
that you mentioned that they essentially
more looser policy I guess okay as
opposed to just yeah so listen I believe
in the sovereignty of countries I think
that there are some interesting
arguments to be made which are sort of
libertarian esque but they actually kind
of go back to humans but in a state of
nature like pre-modern society
where you can just say anybody who wants
to go can go everybody's allowed in
there's no restrictions just anybody who
wants to go I don't think it's practical
I just don't and I think that there's a
sort of ideological argument which is
wouldn't that be nice or wouldn't what
would that that would be a great
philosophical thing I just simply you
know some people say I'm overly
pragmatic it's just not going to work so
I'm okay I'm not an advocate of open
borders in the way that you're
describing what I do think is
problematic is when we have racially
tinged or in other ways politically
discriminatory policies that reinforce
some of the same inequalities that we
claim to be trying to fix that's what I
have a problem with but I'm not an open
borders guy yeah I got yeah I have the
same feeling it's su acai it's all right
ideally it would be a nice idea but it
doesn't seem to me that it could anyway
work unless we get to a point maybe look
this in long in the future worse you
know circumstances are different but I
don't ya know the current circumstance I
think what I'm saying is it's not
practical re great to hear from you I
think Ari and I were in a kind of like
an argument last time he called in yeah
this was a lot more it did it did go
well